all right this is just huge breaking
news tonight Sarah Carter will join us
in a minute is reporting and we have
confirmed with three separate sources
that the Clinton bought and paid for
fake news Russia propaganda dossier was
in fact used in part to obtain FISA
warrants to surveil members of the Trump
campaign and Trump transition now this
means that Hillary Clinton and the DNC
remember that Donna Brazile said Hillary
controlled the DNC they paid millions
and millions of dollars for what is a
totally phony document full of Russian
lies and propaganda that was then used
by the Obama administration to surveil
members of an opposition party an
incoming president this is the same
dossier that former FBI director James
Comey testified under oath as being
salacious and unverified and that
information is only the tip of the
iceberg Sarah Carter reporting and we
are also learning that more shocking
information will be coming out in just
days that will show systemic FISA abuse
this is the real Russia scandal the real
Russia collusion story now the dossier
was used to target an opposition party
and criminalize political differences
now that's the real story that's what
the media has not and will not cover and
Democrats do not want you to know
anything about but unfortunately they
will be forced to cover the story
all of this is unprecedented in the
history of this country this is a sober
moment you need to understand this we
are on the precipice of one of the
largest abuses of power in US American
history and I'm talking about the
literal shredding of the US Constitution
your Fourth Amendment rights against
unreasonable search and seizure it is
that serious now there's new information
is confirming what we have now been
saying and predicting for months on this
show the powerful tools of intelligence
have now been politicized and used to
influence a presidential election now
make no mistake about this this scandal
will reach the highest levels of the
Obama intelligence community the DOJ the
FBI and what we're reporting on is only
the beginning tonight I'll talk to Sarah
Carter about
all the details in a minute and also
tonight the president continuing to
crush the destroy Trump liberal media
and the left completely false narrative
about Russia collusion it has now been
over a year and so far they have zero
zip nada nothing no evidence of Trump
Russia collusion during a press
conference today with Norway's prime
minister the president was asked about
the Russia investigation and if he would
do an interview with Special Counsel
Robert Muller here's his answer take a
look
there has been no collusion between the
Trump campaign and Russians or Trump and
Russians no collusion when you talk
about interviews Hillary Clinton had an
interview where she wasn't sworn in she
wasn't given the oath that in take notes
they didn't record and it was done on
the fourth of July weekend that's
perhaps ridiculous and a lot of people
looked upon that as being a very serious
breach and it really was but again I'll
speak to attorneys I can only say this
there was absolutely no collusion
everybody knows that every committee
I've been in office now for 11 months
for 11 months they've had this phony
cloud over this administration over our
government and it has hurt our
government it does hurt our government
it's a Democrat hoax that was brought up
as an excuse for losing an election that
frankly the Democrats should have won
because they have such a tremendous
advantage in the electoral college so it
was brought up for that reason but it
has been determined that there is no
collusion and by virtually everybody I
will say this I am for massive oil and
gas and everything else and a lot of
energy
Putin can't love that I am for the
strongest military that the United
States ever had
Putin can't love that but Hillary was
not for a strong military and Hillary my
opponent was for windmills now the
president is right on several key points
here first of all like he has been
saying for months like we have been
saying there is no evidence of Trump
Russia collusion this has been a
conspiracy theory manufactured by the
industrial fake news
complex that has been spread night after
night
hour after hour by the likes of CNN and
conspiracy TV MSNBC and as we have been
showing you the narrative is falling
completely flat so now the media is
trying to attack the president his
mental health which is completely
ridiculous so idiotic for so many
reasons for example just yesterday we
could all see the president was in full
control of that immigration debate at
the White House and that he had all of
his faculties but that doesn't stop your
media from lying to you now the other
key point is the president is making now
is that key Democrats remember they've
all said that they have not seen any
evidence of collusion don't take my word
for it let's take their word for it well
that you know the allegation of course
is that the Russians in the hacking and
dumping of documents in the election had
essentially relationships with Trump
campaign people but I'm not prepared to
say that there's proof you could take to
a jury do you agree with this conclusion
that the president has reached there was
no evidence of collusion you know we
haven't seen any of that whatsoever
George we've been looking and showing
everything that they possibly have that
has not led to that the last time we
spoke senator I asked you if you had
actually seen evidence of collusion
between the Trump campaign and the
Russians and you said to me and I'm
quoting you know you said not at this
time has anything changed since we spoke
last well not you know it hasn't I know
we need to go soon but just to be clear
we haven't there has been no actual
evidence yet no it has not been no not
yet now all of that is reason why
president Trump tweeted out today quote
the single greatest witch hunt in
American history continues there was no
collusion everybody including the
Democrats no there was no collusion you
can get on and on it goes Russia and the
world is laughing at the stupidity that
they are witnessing Republicans should
finally take control make no mistake
about it this is a political witch-hunt
unlike anything this country has ever
seen before and it continues to be
exposed and as we have now been
reporting for months the Special Counsel
Robert Muller his investigation is
nothing but a cesspool
saluté cesspool of corruption members of
his team they don't donate to
Republicans but over 50 grand to
Democrats including giving money to
Hillary Clinton and Barack Obama one
lawyer actually represented Hillary in
one particular case and none of them
contributed to the Trump campaign ki
Muller prosecutors also a massive
massive conflicts of interest including
jeanne ray serving as a lawyer for the
Clinton Foundation this is insanity it's
a partisan investigation it's meant to
unseat a duly elected president that the
people voted for President Trump was
also weighing in on the fake news
dossier and hammering senator Feinstein
for unilaterally releasing the testimony
from fusion GPS co-founder Glenn Simpson
the president responded also on Twitter
the fact that Sneaky Dianne Feinstein
who has on numerous occasions stated
that collusion between Trump Russia has
not been found would release testimony
in such an underhanded and possibly
illegal way totally without
authorization as a disgraced must have a
tough primary I don't know about
California but given the new information
we're reporting on tonight about the
dossier it is clear senator Feinstein
and the Democrats they are now tonight
trying to create a massive distraction
they want to hide the truth and you also
heard Feinstein admit just a few seconds
ago
she has personally seen no evidence of
Trump Russia collusion remember that's
what this whole investigation was
supposed to be about but since we
haven't seen any evidence Democrats are
now desperately trying to change the
subject they don't want you to know that
their former candidate Hillary Clinton
and the administration of their former
president their beloved Barack Obama was
actually targeting the Trump campaign
this way once all these details come out
and once the dust settles and all the
people have been screaming about Trump
Russia collusion they will have a lot of
explaining to do and that includes the
media they also may want to lawyer up a
number of them join